UITableViews have two delegate
protocols, with a total of 44 methods.
The two protocols
are the UITableViewDelegate,
which governs responses to user events,
and
the UITableViewDataSource, which enables
the table to access data in cells.
So, think of the delegate as
being associated with events.
And the data source is being associated
with data, appropriately enough.
The table uses its delegate protocol
to ask event questions like these.
What should happen when
a button in a cell is tapped?
What should be the response
to cell selection,
how should I respond when
a user begins editing a row?
What should happen when
a cell is deselected,
the table uses it's data source protocol
to ask data questions like these.
How many rows do I have,
how many sections do I have?
What are the titles for the sections,
what is the cell view for each row?
Here I've opened the class reference for
the UITableViewDelegate.
Where you can find a complete
list of the protocols methods.
Many are related to managing sections,
like the ones we saw in the context and
settings apps.
Don't worry about those as much for
now, since we'll be focusing
on single section tables.
Visit the documentation on your own,
skim through the list.
And for each method,
think about the question that
the view is asking its delegate.
When you're done,
answer the quiz question.
Think of yourself as a table.
If you could only ask three
of these questions and
you needed to build a single section
table, which would you pick?